hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to meta I am to finish
this full conversion mod in this episode
so hopefully we'll see what mysteries
unravel in this horrible guys now why I
didn't open the last episode all that
well but why the hell you gotta bring
that in here I hope that was puking yeah
alright then my guess is that he
actually hook back and then blew up
everywhere what the hell is happening
whoa Search Widget hey oh I've never oh
my goodness I knew there was gonna be
new stuff in here but he made the tree
move Oh
rody alright then it's awfully
disconcerting to seeing see things
moving that aren't supposed to be moving
okay then
well I guess I'm down here now this is a
good idea so glad oh oh is that a carpet
of ladders that's a soap river of blood
oh good it's a river I was hoping for
that with all my heart okay alright then
what do you got in store for me huh we
got in store for me come on bring it on
bring it on bring it on
oh okay does it tricks Kristen
yeah no no not the puppy stop Oh No
fight oh okay okay
how's horrible for some reason me that X
me more than like the people getting
tortured I don't know why cuz I know
it's a game winces two people boys two
doggies I'm like oh I know this might
seem unbelievable but this is exciting
why we were ordered to create beasts so
we'll hunt the prisoners that try to
escape but this process became immense
pleasure you I have never felt so much
relief Oh torturing the animals their
mutilation and deformation became
everyday routine their squealing became
music to my ears you we have developed
deadly hatred inside of them hatred for
any human they see these dogs are the
result I do not have thee to excuse my
inhuman acts I gave up on being human so
did many of my collaborators Constantine
mahnovski okay alright then so we're
gonna have the doggies from the first
penumbra thought I saw the outline of a
doggy turns out it was just a mushroom
uh-huh Bucci well at least you're not
dead
this is the best thing I can hope for
tiny back ship oh oh oh
Johnny Mike sim you need to protect me
from these creatures of the night
they're dangerous things happening here
that you don't even understand that's
okay I've been waiting for you to
cooking a little bit in my sauna
okay tied about sim we got doggie
creatures hood protein for me right I
may throw you at them don't do that let
me joy bye hi hi okay
okay all right okay dodge downside amok
Jim let's go let's go let's go Poochie
yeah poochie's gonna come after me huh I
got oh this looks bad
okay okay okay we're fine we're fine
we're fine come along with me tiny box
Tim there's surely not gonna be more of
them oh look it's a big eagle statue
that scared me before
no no no don't drop that goddamn my
mouse has been freaking out I swear it's
not running out of batteries okay yeah
when crying children arrive everything's
gonna die I'm crying people arrive
everything's gonna be all right okay so
those gates aren't open that way yet God
where am I going what am i doing in this
place Sal area 1 Oh God so much blood
why is there all this blood why must oh
oh oh my goodness well thank you for
being creepy and disturbing
come along Tim oh oh okay oh okay
okay then and do I need I need one of
these doughnut here I'm okay on sanity
super sanity
hi oh no no no no oh you don't
Tim Tim come along Tim tink along oh I
did you know okay that's normal that's
alright don't make those sounds you
weirdos well it's just the weirdest
thing I've started to like know oh god
okay I just ran out by normal means
I'll buy dip don't hug him sorry I got a
little blood on you boy that's okay
carrying on I don't know what like I've
identified the same thing that creeps my
skin and triple phobia
Tripta phobia whoa what is all what is
that oh my goodness
Tim investigate it's kind of comfortable
actually okay then
hey what in the hell are you holy crap
gonna get a good look at you Oh
why are you barking where is it barking
okay let's go towards the flaming skull
of all things
oh no no save the flaming skull for last
of course
ahh moaning oh not at all right what do
you hello Tim you want a ride oh no
thanks okay alright then something weird
is happening in this game okay I do now
you're doing all right
oh good burning blood out of a pulsation
GUP throb oh good more of those things I
don't know what they are
okay don't like him okay they didn't
move oh we're playing we're playing I
don't know some game where I open
[ __ ] lag okay what the Helen happening
okay everything's gone horribly wrong
whoa oh okay then hi doggie how's it
going let's go okay I'll just go over
this way that dog you can stay there I
don't know what's going on in this game
it's a little bit wonky all right
don't know where I'm supposed to go oh I
guess here is obviously a good path
all right seems like the developer added
a whole bunch of stuff to this game that
was the first time that it actually
slowed down the game
we're like what is that ah who drew this
art was it the developer they have a
twisted sense of artistic stuff no Tim
Tim Tim I lost Tim they took away the
only thing that mattered in this world
well that was a less than encouraging
message when try that again buddy
what is going on here Tim I miss him
already
Oh blue Darian what does that mean
someone in the comments will translate
that Oh blood Darian Oh blow a bully
okay so now we've entered a sort of
medical facility oh no never mind it's
turned into Frankenstein's lab all right
then okay all right okay
what is that Oh and or foreign memories
that's what I get for touching oh now
earning for memories the events you will
witness happen in the past I got that
look what did you talk to me this is not
part of our agreement what about your
treason was that part of our agreement
please you must understand oh this is
wrong is it you wanted to betray us all
and we feel a secret to the public you
will be punished for that
yeah punished take the venom and force a
traitor to drink it Wow what is this
like one of those Call of Duty moments
words like no I don't want to okay you
can't drag it kind of willingly he
gulped it down what you deserve
the venom was an experiment let's wait
and see how painful your death will be
how painful will your death be oh do
then this is seen the things we did
we're wrong probably you are weak
maybe this will shut your mouth for good
okay then I got some time passed after
the event took place in the effects of
the venom began hi sir
it is something out of control
a few thought if it wants to kill us Oh
it seems that huh I can tell by the look
on his face continue your work there is
no way
you mean wall glass wall enough with its
nonsense that poor person does not
deserve your cool wait what is going on
the foreign member ends here dude it the
death of memories owner memoria so nur
I'm guessing this is a pile of dead body
said that creature took over oh good
good good good good that's all good sure
make him into a horrible creature
monster whoa whoa cuz I like the black
goop that he travels through is he like
uh what's his name from okay alright
then I didn't do that
alright uh I would run if you'd stop
looking at it
Oh what am i running why am i running
where am i running to this run is very
urgent let me tell you
dramatic up the yin-yang okay yeah I ran
successfully I think do I still need a
run what's going on here alrighty then
big giant door that tells ya this one's
looping personal general during the last
routine of prison keepers work we have
discovered mysterious phenomena we are
not aware of the oldest torturing
complexes but we have seen signs of the
ancient a strange aura could be felt in
the air it was calling to us that
something was behind the solid wall me
and my colleagues decided to break the
wall and check it out we could not
believe our eyes there are secret areas
inside it looked like sacred boom we
started to investigate that place
everything was fine until that happened
everybody died I was the only one that
was able to return I'm leaving this
organization there is no way I would
return to that place again
Baltazar and raava okey dokey then was
oddly close to Balthazar
oh good I dragged from the weird water
in the middle of the dungeon probably in
the ancient area that probably is gonna
fit well alright then I'll crawl through
your weird crackling holes I miss Tim I
miss what tiny barrel oh it's so
adorable
it's a tiny barrel it's freaking
adorable
oh god there's another one oh he's got
his barrel buddies
anybody read barrel buddies oh well I've
got enough tiny oh hello objects 95m do
you know anything about this
ah no medium aren't bodies okay then
weird so I picked up a Mart I picked up
Martello not just a mallet Italian ammo
hammer please wait bash it on this guy's
face okay alright then I'm out of here
weirdos
I don't know what happened here but oh
why do you throw Tim hi no vase I don't
want to come back Tim would you make me
throw Tim weirdos hey Kay what what what
okay what what happened what happened
what happened I didn't see okay those
are selfish Tim stop freaking me up ok
bye ok bye ok bye ok bye
alright bye what behind it was it behind
this wall I can use my Martello to smash
through this wall I think
oh goodness gracious damn I wouldn't
leave you mind not for the whole world
okay off I go then I'm happening
who's doing oh he's chasing me laughs I
did not know
beware the shadow eater oh it's a clever
name and all but I'd rather get the hell
out of here I got interesting is Tim
still there why am i back here what in
the world Lou what's going on wait a
minute
wait a minute here I'll be where the
shadow eater but just as soon as you get
me back to Tim Oh Tim had to leave his
barrel buddies behind where is he where
is he where is he Rosie better be here
better be here there he is okay who
thought I lost you buddy
torch okay I never leave oh you're gonna
leave me fine oh no oops ah damn it damn
it okay
oh I add him just for a bit but at least
I know he's safe at least I know the
monster didn't get him so what else you
got for me a weird game a weird weird
custom story I got made you scare me
something was triggered I'd rather move
faster okay fine I'll move faster huh
save me a lot of traps around here all
right I'm moving I'm moving I'm moving
can't really go much faster okay
okay then what the hell is triggered
you're not gonna tell me are you danger
risk of brain damage well good thing I
got a sanity potion
uh what is this good question that
cannot be real no it's a painting
actually you'll find Oh what is happen I
don't know if you got that creature in
the game I'd be very impressed okay
there's a circle I'm assuming it's a
circle to run around in as I'm scared
like a little baby little baby mater
mater there's a bunch of monsters down
here Bator okay where am I going what am
i doing how's this a goddamn loop
there's no point tannier dad oh wait no
there was another path down here wasn't
there
uh I suppose II use this it's not quite
Martello but it'll do what is going on
in his weird-ass game and what is that
supposed to be all right I hope
everybody is chasing me I don't hear it
okay ah Jimmy move faster please
it's gonna kill it I know it's gonna
kill me oh it's gonna kill me okay all
right suddenly I can spread now yep oh
crap
alright okay that did not work okay so
I'm not gonna be able to climb up on
anything
Oh poopy ope here we go
okay dead guy ass up in the water good
friend yep yep tough guy yeah Oh
sassafras it didn't work
beware there are two levers in the
control room one lever controls the
mechanic door lock system other level
starts appear a process of melting the
bodies the lever on the Left should be
the good one sure sure buddy
I somehow eyes my Tesla prototype
working I can't see okay so there's two
levers somewhere what does that was that
electricity that mean that the door is
electrified it's electrically locked
where am I going okay here we go open no
not gonna open knock it open okay so
where am I going I was in a blind panic
I didn't look at anything else else
running what do you go there you got
what do you got what do you got what do
you got okay here we go now I'm finally
out of the water good to know that my
electrical device doesn't work in the
water all right
tiny buddy sim how you're not tiny yeah
hi oh there oh sorry did that hurt
ten bucks Tim you're gonna be okay it's
all right
I only a little brain damage the wise
saying does us that the one who prays
will fire but burn
unfortunately we're playing with the
water and the result was even worse as
we were told we have developed new kind
of mortification for the Syndicates
victims the process is so intense that
it slowly melts living by human body
into liquid it seemed to work so we were
performing this kind of punishment daily
not nearly knowing what failure we are
doing we were pouring the liquid
remnants into the drainage and that was
the worst thing that we could do because
soon we realize that the melted liquid
still contained tormented souls of the
humans the water came alive and started
to attack everything within its reach we
did a mistake we did horrible mistake we
did mistake stay out of the water at any
cost don't charge the Machine because it
will melt even more human bodies and
definitely do not end up with escape
door or else it will escape the section
and go on a doubt a rampage Jorge eres
la what a solski the head of
experimental Department good job
Warshofsky okay hello pretty lady so the
one a nice ass oh it's a good shot right
there okay one on the Left should be
good
I don't know if that sounded good boy I
feel like it might have been good was
that was that all about
oh no it's like eyes are watching me
alright let's see if that was good that
might open the door I don't know oh good
now I can control my flashlight I think
tiny box sim is what's making that
happen
DynaVox sim you are all sorry bastard
okay sorry
alright so now we can escape and
hopefully get out of here forever I
don't care if I lead a bunch of water oh
that's not good
don't like Jeff save me save me Jim oh
that's him I'm not gonna leave you buddy
no no no no no ha ha ha ha ha alright
well that's not gonna be a problem the
water doors the water monsters can't
water escape whoa what is this that's
definitely some stuff from amnesia a
machine for Pitt whoa some textures
mixing on that one this whoa this room
is blue all of this is split why is it
so forgive me you're forgiven
did you do this that's okay you pried
just uh angry or something
hey where are we going
bye Tim oh must be unlocked first
forbidden section I thought all this
were forbidden okay oh hey it's Jesse
sue what you think you're doing
always that's a pit of acid okay I'm
gonna need like a container for that
don't drop him in the pit acid that's
definitely not something I want to do
doors locked
well good nothing here for me oh here we
go
forbidden sexy key an event must be
reported somebody betrayed us and locked
the escape door it's the only way to get
out but only three keys are present in
the facility I had one key but I found
it broken there's no way to get the two
remaining keys one of those is in
possession of the shadowy jerk the
second key is in the forbidden section
the ribbon section is forbidden for good
reason there is no way anybody could
survive in there I did not witness it
but they say that there is an entity
something that is a worse than hundreds
of shadow eases one good thing is that
the evil inside cannot get out somebody
wants to escape this godforsaken place
they may try to get the key from there
but that means opening a Pandora's box
and unleashing the evil that's inside
sounds good to me
I gotta end this episode here this
carrying on a bit longer than I thought
it would so I'm gonna kind of here and
start the next episode if it ends up
being five minutes long you'll see it
here so thank you everybody so much for
watching click the end of days before
videos that I've done and as always I
will see you in the next video
now you go back a bit
that's funny
flavin